foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in
tidy models it's uh something I've been
working with tele Baldwin with for the
last half year or so and I'm very
excited to
come here and talk to all of you about
it
so before we did any fill I wanted to
have a tweet additional introduction to
what I find most important about tidy
models as a framework
and the three most important things I
see is that it's consistent modular and
extensible
it's consistent in a way that any
function that returns a table will
always return to Tipple if you return a
fitted object it's always a fitted up
yet
and any things like dimensions
with respect to Harlem names and row
numbers will always stay the same so
once you know what a function output you
can reliably code knowing that that will
be the piece
certainly it's modular in the sense that
instead of having one monster function
that will do a bunch of pre-processing
data model inside a trust validation
fold and find the most optimal optimal
model According to some heuristic we
instead create smaller objects that we
can then bind to the
allows us to easily
swap out and build a more complete
workflow
and lastly
and for me most importantly is the idea
of extensibility
so tiny models was built from the ground
up knowing that we needed to make it so
other people could build extensions and
to made
it much more maintainable instead of
having one large pad it's worth hundreds
of thousands of toad that needs to all
be tapped in sync instead we have
smaller more photos patches that had
been handled independently
yet they all still work wonderfully
together
this part is near and dear to my heart
it hurts this is how I started working
with tidy models four years ago when I
started working on my first extension
packet
and now it led me up here we were taught
about another attention package in front
of all of you
so when we think about machine learning
it's a wonderfully
well-defined uh top hit but one of the
ways we can think about it is in the
idea of unsupervised in a supervised
setting
so
um
tidy models right now works really well
in the supervised setting we can do
classification we can do regression as
we just saw we we also are starting to
work on tools to deal with sensor
progression which isn't even on this
diagram we also have tools in the form
of pre-processing to deal with
dimensionality and having a lot of
variables turn it into a smaller
hopefully better set of variables
but there's something very clearing
right in the middle of my diaphragm
right here that we haven't been able to
do for the longest time
and that's what I wanted to that's what
drove me to work on this project is we
want to work with clustering but it just
didn't fit in and it wasn't even a
little happy to make it what it wasn't
possible before
to
do any kind of clustering models
that's why I'm very excited to be the
first Public Announcement
that we're introducing tidy cluster
package
so
you're probably gonna have a couple of
questions or you're fainting something
you're like yes finally I needed this
for years people have been asking people
are trying to teach it we have a lot of
people that try to teach at the classic
intro to statistical machine learning
and you can do almost everything
in tidy models and then you have one
weight where you show clustering and it
just feels off
we're finally here some of you might
think I really appreciate that he's
dressing in the same theme as the slides
but lastly
uh maybe more important question is why
are we building an oil pan
and this comes from some internal
friction
as I mentioned before that tidy models
just wasn't built to do bustering it was
built with supervised models in mind
and there wasn't really any way to to
force it through it just didn't work
and this is because of some fundamental
differences between how clustering
models worked and how a typical
uh supervised models were and the main
thing which in essence is a very but
fundamental property and it seems a
little bit simple but it's
most models have outcomes
and this little yeah of course they have
out terms but it meant that every single
piece of toad we have more or less is
written with outcomes in mind
and it just meant that it didn't work
like we couldn't make it work because
not only do cluster emails not have
outcomes we don't want you to put in
outcomes because
it will be as a symptom of
you're trying to do the wrong thing
we also have the entire models the idea
that we have daily defined predictions
which are then clustering very
controversial topic will still talk
about it but it still is
not the clearly most clearly defined
thing
and lastly related to the idea of
outcomes
having a drowned truth to test your
model attends against means that you do
a performance chatting you can have a
model you hide the outcome data on it
and see do my predictions aligned with
the True Values
that makes it very easy to do normal a
performance metrics we can do no no such
thing
with clustering methods there are
some ways of seeing 10 we made but does
this clustering model appear to be solid
but we don't have any clear answer
nevertheless we still move on and try to
do the best we can
this means that
[Music]
um
I we needed to do a lot of work to Port
over many of the internals of Tidy
models rewrite them from stretch
with the notes with the assumption that
there's no outcomes so it's a lot of
parallel toad but hopefully it means for
all of you
that it would be as seamless a
transition as possible
if you're all really familiar with tidy
models I would wait by reading the
vignettes we have coming up later today
on the Pakistan side
mutant that up and running with tidy
models for a tidy classed in an hour or
two because
we found a valid transition
to show how some of this worked I will
use some very exciting data set so it's
a data set of dates as in the field and
it is
features extracted from images so they
have a bunch of images of dates and
indeed calculated various things of
those
images so that the area will be the
number of pixels that contain the fruit
we have perimeter eccentricity we also
have
and I do we are down we also have
various things about the RGB colors of
those images so there's a lot happening
in here and we're hoping to see if just
by having these visual metrics about
these days if we can pull out some
clusters
two things you will notice about this
data is some of these values have quite
different ranges so something like the
area is in the order of hundreds of
thousands and something like
eccentricity is quite a low value so if
if our clustering model has any type of
stale sensitivity we need to deal with
that additionally we have a lot of these
the predictors being quite correlated so
generally for most shapes we have that
the area perimeter targets areas are
roughly related and likewise something
like the tallest if there's a lot of
blue in a picture there might not be as
much of the Euler color so like we have
a lot of tolerations
which we can see in this turbulation
matrix it's a little too small to
actually see what different things are
what we are seeing
huge chunks of highly correlated
variables and highly deteriorated
variables so we might want to have to
deal with that as well
so we start out the same way we do in
parsnip by creating a clustering model
specification so here we are doing a
simple K means and we write it out and
we did a t means cluster specification
we have yet another mode here we talked
about a partition
so
we say a partition is when every
observation will be assigned one and
only one cluster
later down the line we want to expand
our the White surface to use extractive
clustering where
any one observation can be in zero or
more clusters
so that is right on that in the on the
horizon
bloodline how we can specify a single
faster specification here using the
default engine in the stat path hit
we can also set the number of clusters
we can change the engine or add engine
specific things another thing we really
try to work hard on as we do in positive
and other packages is have
uh more descriptive names so instead of
having K and H we will instead name it
something like num clusters or taught
Heist so you don't have to know as much
jaten moving around
with this model specification we can now
work with the rest of Tidy models so
here we are creating a specification and
we said we wanted to normalize the data
I'm dealing with the correlations
by
applying some PCA keeping the
the most variable principal components
and we can do that easily put it into a
workflow and fit this workflow
and if you take a trade node you will
see that this is very very similar to
everything else we're doing in tidy
models the only two differences is
instead of see instead of specifying as
a
a parsnip object we instead trading our
tidy clustered up yet
and in the recipe we are not specifying
an outcome
but everything else should work
smoothly so there's very little new
things for you to learn
once we have a fitted workflow
we now have an object we want to do
certain calculations with Strat dot see
what happens inside
traditionally a lot of that word was
dilated in the broom package
while amazing has been drawing a lot and
have drawn pain so we are rewriting a
lot of that functionality on our new
engines to stay consistent and work the
way we want it to
some of the things we can do is pull out
what cluster Egypt observations were
found in in our cluster model
we always did a typical pad here named
that cluster so it's always the same
additionally we
have done some retention something time
salutation of the cluster names so in a
case like K means it costs as a random
but we are stopping some of that brain
dominance from coming through so you're
more likely to
actually have consistent clusters across
at bootstraps
another thing we can do is pull out
where those Clauses are located we can
do that with the striped centroids
and then with a note here that since we
had a wet had a workflow with a recipe
the the centroids are based on where the
data
centers are based in the data space that
was passed to the cluster model which in
this case was the PCS that came out of
the recipe
and lastly we are a little on the Edge
by saying that some of these engines
also allow for prediction so prediction
is a little bit of a touchy subject but
in for every different model we have
described what we actually mean by it
and in the taste of Tay means it means
which cluster
uh centroid are you closest to
and these words
and then with the whole workflow so the
pre-processing will happen so you don't
have so you don't have those sneaky data
leaders that happens by doing PC before
and everything like that
while I talked about how something like
something like metrics
can be tried hard to calculate there
still is a number of metrics that we
would like to do
so
in the same style as yardstick we have a
number of metrics
that are specific to these cluster fits
so here we have a function that tells us
the total with it
total of in some of thread errors
and
to calculate that it's not just a metric
comparing an outcome to
a round truth instead we are calculating
a metric based on the centroids and the
observations this metric is summing up
how far the points are from that
clusters
and in the same style we if we have
multiple we interpine them in a cluster
metric set
to calculate multiple metrics as one
so so far I talked a lot about that just
I fitted one model that to do that where
we arbitrarily set the number of
clusters to be five but ideally we would
like to find out how many clusters of
video
we'll never know but maybe we can see
which clusters would be the best ones
so we're going on to tuning so we can
spit we can specify that the number of
clusters should be tuned I try a bunch
of different things
we set up a trade of different values we
say I want to see something between 1
and 10 plus that would probably be best
it's a fairly small data set if not we
can move on
and then we have a function tune cluster
that word almost this what has the same
use of the interface as
the tune functions you're familiar with
from tune and fine tune so you pass in a
word flow or a cluster specification you
give it some resamples and Twitter
values
and here we can also specify some
cluster metrics
so the only difference here than your
usual word flow is you want to use tune
cluster instead of tune Drive
and then you can optionally pass in a
custom set of
uh metric functions
and then once all that runs clean you
that bad the same type of assault that
you did for most of the tune functions
so you tend to let metrics let
predictions select Best Buy auto plot
and so on I'm not saying you should do
select best because as we have here in a
k means when the number of clusters
throw up this method will always go down
it is just a reality but this can easily
be combined with something like gdplot
to create an elbow chart or any Euler
diagnostic you may have made that you
may want to do
that's all I have for you today there's
more uh word over here we have
some Indians I'm gonna try to merge as
soon as I turn off that is taught
um the main takeaway I want for you
is I want you to use the package we're
still in very early development most of
the foundation is here
in the sense that everything works
hopefully but
but we want I want to know what you want
to do because we still are missing
more types of metrics engines and models
so I want to hear all of that
[Music]